est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
cacher le corps de quelqu'un qui vient
de tuer
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au stade
est-ce que par amour vous pouvez quitter
votre travail votre ville ou vos amis on
travaille non le travail non très
carriériste il faut vraiment que ce soit
fort fort parce que quitter le boulot
c'est je suis prête à quitter mon
travail surtout mon travail le travail
oui la ville oui ma ville ouais mes amis
ça dépend lesquels est-ce que par amour
pour y arrêter de fumer de boire et de
draguer
et la dernière question c'était arrêter
de draguer
vous seriez prête à héberger ses parents
son ex ou un terroriste les deux
premiers sans problème dans quoi qu'en
fait non avec c'est super bizarre de
diverses quand même
ses parents préférence le terroriste oui
peut-être un terroriste
plutôt un terroriste pas du tout
terroriste
à la chirurgie esthétique non
certainement pas non oui je peux avoir
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
que vous apprenez que vous avez un rival
est-ce que vous serez capable de
partager de pardonner ou de tuer
pardonnez peut-être le reste c'est tout
pardonné parce que ça a déjà eu lieu de
tuer de tuer est-ce que vous seriez
prête par amour à vivre à trois avec sa
meuf impossible ménager à trois mois non
moi je suis pas très libérée en termes
de couple
de femmes avec deux femmes
oui
est-ce que vous seriez prête par amour
allez tous les soirs dans un club
échangiste non
non non je pense pas tous les soirs
une fois par mois
ça se passe mais si c'est vraiment comme
dans les films
roter un petit cocktail ça lui fait
vraiment plaisir pourquoi pas
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser 100 fois ces chaussettes sales
oui
j'adore les défis c'est moi qui fait les
lessives donc bon peut-être
[Musique]